young kurds come to the Mesopotamia
Culture Centre in Istanbul to cultivate
their music and language a right that
turkeys Kurdish minority long fought for
after 35 years of civil strife the
government in Ankara has extended a hand
to the Kurds the Kurds of neighbouring
Iraq are one step further standing on
the brink of a national state of their
own
I suppose if that would mean an
opportunity for us to express our
demands even more forcefully and the
Iraqi Kurds ought to support us just as
we support them but we also shouldn't
forget our brothers and sisters in Iran
and Syria
a bill is the capital of the Iraqi
Kurdistan region the Iraqi capital
Baghdad is faraway geographically and
politically the autonomous regions
president Massoud Barzani is taking
advantage of the ongoing conflict
between Sunnis and Shiites to advance
the cause of an independent state a
fully independent Kurdistan would be a
dream come true for Nihad koja air
bill's mayor since 2004 when the city's
population was half a million now it's
more than doubled in size the traders at
the bazaar think highly of him
many of the older generation fought for
their people's freedom as guerrillas in
the mountains
the mayor says those days are gone now
at least for the Kurds of northern Iraq
the freedom we have now makes us feel
secure and everyone here makes an effort
to support and defend this freedom we
have our own military organization
Secret Service and police another factor
is the spectacular economic development
of Iraqi Kurdistan new high-rises and
shopping centers are popping up all over
Erbil most of them built by Turkish
developers Turkey the Kurds one-time
arch nemesis has turned into Kurdistan's
biggest investor the returns come
largely in the form of oil Iraqi
Kurdistan takes charge of its own oil
exports the Kurdish leadership is
delighted that turkey no longer treats
the Kurds as enemies so Kurdistan is
pursuing its own national security and
kurdistan's really wants to have a nice
balanced relations with all the
neighbors it's a win-win situation it's
not only that turkey is a Kurdistan is
winning from the relation with Turkey
turkey is also winning in that
relationship with Kurdistan and that's
the way of doing politics on the
neighborhood Erbil is City Hall the
Kurdish administration is still a work
in progress
whenever problems crop up the mayor
steps in personally he lived in Germany
over 20 years where he learned about
Western systems of government but his
booming city is attracting more people
than it can accommodate I remember very
well that up until three or four years
ago we had to demolish over 12,000
houses that have been put up illegally
because it's Finnish illegal via Silas
but we provided the residents with lots
and funding to build their own homes
according to the building code to
establish more order in the city most of
the Iraqi Kurds welcomed turkeys support
and would like to see more some could
even imagine a Turkish Kurdish federal
voices around the bazaar say that would
bring them closer to the European Union
just look at the history of the Kurds
we've always been the pawn of the world
powers and now the West can help make up
for it by supporting us our future
depends even more on the EU and the
United States than on Turkey
many of the Kurds in Istanbul are also
dreaming of an independent Kurdistan but
they're watching developments in Iraq
and waiting to me personally the Kurdish
leader in northern Iraq Massoud Barzani
is two feudal and conservatives I'm
happy to see them making progress but
politically I'd like a different
Kurdistan with or without independence
many Kurds see a brighter future